[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: When it
comes to security,
Google Cloud is never finished.
There's always room
for improvement,
and our newest
security improvement
is providing keyless
authentication
for service accounts.
When your application
needs to access services
in Google Cloud outside
of the scope of a user,
it probably uses
a service account.
Service accounts
allow developers
to assign an identity
to an application
and then give that identity
specific permissions,
for example, to access
a cloud storage bucket.
Service account keys are
akin to user passwords,
allowing the holder to act as
the service account and gain
access to any resource that
service account has access to.
Unfortunately, there's
no way to verify
that the application holding the
key has permission to use it.
It's a key without
an expiration date
and with no guarantee
around where it's stored
or who has access to it.
Because of this risk, managing
the storage, distribution,
and rotation of
service account keys
becomes a top
priority, effectively
turning an identity management
problem into a secrets
management problem.
So what's the solution?
Ditch the keys.
Workload identity
federation enables
applications running
outside of Google Cloud
to replace long-lived
service account
keys with temporary
credentials, also called tokens.
Workload identity federation
is a keyless application
authentication mechanism for
calling Google Cloud APIs.
It works by first having
your application authenticate
to your identity provider and
receive account credentials.
The application can then call
our security token service
to exchange the account
credentials issued
by your identity provider for a
short-lived Google Cloud access
token.
This access token can then be
used to impersonate a service
account, inheriting the
permissions of that service
account to access
Google Cloud resources.
To set up workload
identity federation,
you'll first need to create
a workload identity pool
in your Google Cloud project.
Fortunately, you don't need to
be a super admin to do this.
You only need permission
to manage workload identity
pools, service accounts, and IAM
policies at the project level.
A workload identity pool allows
you to organize and manage
external identities.
A project can have multiple
pools with each one
allowing access from a different
external identity provider.
This allows you to create
collections of identities
and easily control the
permissions granted
to identities from
each identity provider.
Then, configure a one-way trust
between your identity provider
and the workload identity pool
by providing relevant metadata
about your provider.
Now, when an application
attempts to exchange their IDP
credential, the
security token service
will be able to validate
that the credential is
from a trusted provider
before issuing an access
token to the application.
Finally, you'll need to
create an IAM policy that
allows identities in the
workload identity pool
to impersonate the
service account.
With these policies
in place, we're
now set up to properly
authenticate the application.
We've mitigated a security risk
while maintaining the ability
to reliably make Google
Cloud API requests.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
To learn more about how
workload identity federation can
help you better protect
your Google Cloud access,
check out the blog post.
To try it out for yourself, be
sure to see the documentation
to start your keyless
security adventure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]